everyone wants to get that new christmas
sweater but all those sweaters as fun as
they may be are part of a big
sustainability problem facing the
garment industry there's a lot of
inefficiency in the supply chain today
there's environmental problems there's
social problems because there's a very
exploitative nature of some of the
supply chains and then you also have the
customer experience for the brands and
retailers it takes a long while and
there to hold a lot of inventory design
produce sell
that's standard procedure for the
industry these days
but new technologies are poised to shake
that up by eliminating waste and
infusing sustainability into the supply
chain
creating a new paradigm design sell
produce
one company involved in this is software
automation who is developing robots that
manufacture on-demand clothing using 3d
printing technology we apply advanced
machine vision technology computer
vision
along with ai and robotics to
essentially
allow us to work with fabric which is
extremely flexible and stretchy and all
kinds of good stuff and then create from
roll of fabric to a finished garment in
this case t-shirt what it does is it
allows us to
re-imagine how clothing is produced and
having it made on demand in local supply
chains closest to the customer we want
to be focused on zero inventory
initiatives which means e-commerce small
brands online merchants who don't have
the capacity or don't want to carry
inventory so we started with them as the
core customer base
for the initial factory one such
potential customer would be designers
like ganec goldstein my workflow
includes
3d body scan so i'm scanning the body
to get the exact measurements of
specific
person so i can design
this garment in three dimensional space
and
3d printing it afterwards the future is
really about customization so you can
design your own clothes it's a file like
we are sending a
png and jpeg it's just a different
format everyone wants to be unique i
know about myself that i always want to
buy clothes that no one else has so for
music customization is really coming
from a personal perspective and i think
that's the new revolution that's
happening that we can
make our own clothes much more locally
than it is now
streamlining the manufacturing process
and eliminating oversupply could have
huge positive impacts for an industry
that struggles with its own
disposability
the average consumer now buys 60 more
clothing than they did in 2000 and each
item is kept half as long
these habits contribute to the 39
million tons of post-consumer textile
waste that is generated worldwide each
year
most of it clothing software automation
claims their process results in 50
percent less environmental impact than
traditional methods a number derived
from being conscious of every step in
the manufacturing process the entire
process of how you source the cotton
from the most sustainable farms
then how you finish and die
and then how you make every step of the
way you're using the most cutting-edge
technology
to eliminate all those greenhouse
emissions and water usage we essentially
have what we call zero discharge of
water that means we consume all the
water and recycle all the water we use
as we get to scale we expect that we'll
save about 500 million
gallons of water a year
for consumers one of the main appeals of
fast fashion is the price tag
but low prices in part come from
exploitive labor practices and mass
production palin islami says that
doesn't have to be part of the equation
with our current rollout in our current
factories we are cost competitive with
uh imported product today
all made in the us we're also building
in circularity into our business model
up front so that when consumers are done
with the shirt they can send it back to
us and we can recycle that the base
fabric and yarn back into
fresh new products as well the other
thing that we pride on making with our
product is we are making the best
quality share
goldstein feels clothes made with these
new technologies may cost more but that
consumers will still find value in them
i don't think that cheap is actually
something that close needs to be
it has to have value instead of buying
10 clothes i could buy one
shirt fit to my own needs and i think
it's also about the size a lot of people
buy online and it's just not a good fit
and with the technology of swedish body
scan it's actually much much much easier
to fit but at the end of the day experts
like lauren bravo say the best way to
eliminate waste is by buying less and
shopping second hand the rule that i
tend to apply to clothes shopping
generally which is second hand first
so before you go out and buy anything
brand new for yourself ask yourself
actually could i get it second hand and
increasingly at the moment the answer is
going to be yes so instead of that
sweater perhaps some other gifts may be
the way to go green this christmas i
think we're starting to see people more
interested in actually not acquiring
more stuff that's going to sit on a
shelf and gather dust but instead
presents like a voucher for your
favorite restaurant may be tickets for a
concert at least that you know they're
probably going to be used and enjoyed
rather than sitting in the back of a
closet
[Music]